I like this tweet that V put out the
other day day I don't know if he said it
would be day one but I think it should
be day one immediately fire half of uh
like the the DC bureaucrats or the civil
servants just you know transfer them I'm
good with firing them I think like if if
automatically there's half of them I
mean obviously we could talk about the
economic comp uh I guess implications of
that many people being out of a out of a
job but if it's like if the federal
government is so huge where we actually
need to talk about The Economic
Consequences of that many civil servants
losing their jobs then that's a problem
he was saying layoffs because that
bypasses the restrictions you can lay
them off for budgetary reasons and yes
absolutely and uh I would I would I
would hope that
V to the extent it is legally humanly
and economically possible maximizes
those layoffs there's no there's no you
know what it is so we were talking last
night about schools and I was saying
like abolish the doe and get rid of this
broken system